[Music]
[Applause]
Marcus Spears ESPN analyst former
defensive end and you can see him on NFL
live every afternoon weekdays for
Eastern with Minik KES Laura rutage Dan
orlovski Ryan Clark also you can catch
him on Monday night countdown as well he
joins us on the program great to see you
again swagu if I didn't watch the game
last night how would you describe it how
would you sum it up uh masteral
performance from kurk cousins and this
offense and a masterful masterful
performance from Brian Flores the
defensive coordinator from Minnesota um
listen man I'm not going
to um dismiss the fact that Debo Samuel
and Trent Williams didn't play that's a
big deal for that team and what they
like to do but we know what this league
is and you got to overcome that
sometimes times I I give Minnesota all
the credit in the world this was a two
and five football team coming into this
game um last night on Monday Night
countdown every one of us picked the San
Francisco 49ers and I'm sure most of
America did as well if you wasn't a
viking fan but I think what they did
last night um should boost this team but
more importantly walking away from the
performance that Kurt Cousins put
together against a defense that we all
respect and have a lot of um a lot of
admiration for uh was what would
probably be the story of the game uh for
me but also you can say the Niners
didn't have Debo or Trent Williams but
the Vikings didn't have the best
receiver in the game and Justin
Jefferson absolutely it looked like they
did though with Jordan Anderson yeah uh
do you have more concern for the ners or
more hope for the
Vikings
probably probably more I I would walk
away from that game more hope for the
Vikings
um now look they dug themselves a big
hole but they they made a they made a
good move to try to get out of it uh
with that win last night I'm not worried
about the 49ers man um it's too large of
a sample size of of Kyle Shanahan is too
large of a sample size of when all of
these guys are healthy now which is a
big deal now DP like we know injuries
happened in this league and they got to
figure out a way to overcome it when dvo
is not available um who I think changes
that entire offense we could talk about
Brandon auk being the number one wide
receiver we could talk about Christian
mcaffrey and how great he is for sure
Debo Samuel is the guy that changes the
picture for that offense with what he
does after the catch so missing him you
miss a big part see here's the
difference you not only miss a player
when it comes to Debo Samuel you miss a
scheme you miss the way you're able to
call plays which is a completely
different thing than when we just
talking about a really good player being
out of the game like Justin Jefferson to
your point with the Minnesota Vikings
but um I I think the Minnesota Vikings
one needed that win but more importantly
they needed a win against a really good
team to say look man we still we still
can pull that out of ourselves when need
be I'm trying to figure out who I know
is real like after six seven games I
like are the Eagles okay you you got a A
solid feeling about them the Chiefs do
you have a solid feeling like how many
teams do you go I know exactly who you
are DP I think if we had to hang out
head on on two people or teams in this
league it's Kansas City and Philly okay
right like the most consistent thing in
the NFL is Patrick Mahomes um regardless
of whatever it could be absolute chaos
around the rest of this league he's
going to be he's going to be that one
thing in the NFL that you drop into any
game on Sunday and you feel like his
team can win no matter what the
circumstances are because of who he is
and feel with their the way that they
play football as long as look and and
this is a big as long as as of right now
the turnovers are a problem in Philly
right now but they are so talented and
so able to play the game the way they
want to um that they can overcome that
unlike many other teams I mean shoot we
saw San Francisco last night turn the
ball over three times and they couldn't
overcome it Philly turns it over and
they overcome it I mean that's a six and
one football team and obviously you
point to the loss against the Jets which
is a which is a bad loss for them but
ultimately they still had a chance to
win that game with three turnovers in
that game as well so Philly and Kansas
City right now and and DP I don't know
why the hell okay we we
always Kansas city is going to be good
they are going to be in the playoffs
they are the more the most sure thing in
the NFL regardless of how we get into
how they look in certain games or the
offense is not clicking or as new wide
receivers we got to see if they gonna
come along the Kansas City Chiefs are
the shest thing in the NFL and obviously
is because of Pat but it's also Travis
Kelce it's also Andy Reid and that staff
and oh by the way this year they got a
top five defense in the
NFL talking to Marcus Spears of the
mothership former NFL defensive end what
would you do against the brotherly shove
the tush push as a defensive player and
what do you think about that play I
don't have a problem with the play at
all DP I think this league is about
finding an advantage about finding
something you can do that nobody can
stop cuz I know if there's a defensive
call that you can make that is going to
guarantee a sack every time you call it
teams will be calling it every year
every game every second um so that's how
I feel about the idea of the brotherly
show now DP let's get into some old
school football you remember when I was
on set with you at the Super Bowl in
Arizona and I put my hands on y'all and
almost threw y'all over that balcony
yeah um I think what you have to do um
is not what's allowed in this league
anymore you you you got to try to make
these offensive linemen
hate having to do the tush push and that
means getting under them that means
taking knees out um not not injury but
when we used to play goal line when I
was in the league we would try to make
the offensive lineman flat for our
linebackers to be able to come over the
top and when I say takeing knees out I
don't want people to get it misconstrued
ain't trying to tear no ACLS or nothing
like that you are literally trying to
cut the offensive lineman so all of your
guys on the second level can come over
the top and it becomes a one-on-one
tackle with the quarterback the issue
that people have with the Philadelphia
Eagles is Jaylen Herz is as strong as
all of his offensive line so that's why
it's so successful there um but I don't
I don't think I don't think there should
even be a conversation about taking it
out of the game it's an advantage that
the Philadelphia Eagles been found and
they should use it until it don't work
anymore yeah I'm not concerned about
Jaylen Herz getting hurt I'm I'm
concerned about those offensive and
defensive linemen if you want to take it
out of the game for safety and K
Kelsey's even talked about this like it
it's brutal on these offensive linemen
and I wonder if they can use it kind of
under
that uh I don't know that curtain of hey
these guys could get hurt and it's all
about safety but if you have an
advantage and they they run that how
many what were the numbers Paulie on the
Eagles using it like 75 times they they
out of 7 seven tries they only didn't
get it three times and that was on third
down and they got it on a subsequent
fourth down yeah and nobody's even 93%
with thing right now yeah yeah nobody I
I don't have a problem with it it's
their advantage if anybody else is going
to be able to do it uh then go ahead and
do it if I said you could have Travis
Kelce or Tyreek
Hill oh
we that's that's probably one of the
greatest questions I've ever gotten DP I
would probably have to
go
Tyreek dang it and that's hard um I just
think he influences what you have to do
defensively more than anybody in the NFL
um and he has the one thing that
regardless of um ability that you can't
really defend and that speed his speed
is different than everybody else's and I
think when you have I'm not even talking
about the playmaking ability if you ask
me as far as these two guys making plays
I would probably take Kelsey because
Kelsey is with and he's also with
Mahomes
but he the critical Downs is what I
think Travis Kelce is is the guy that
you would want and most of the time you
in those situations in big games but as
far as taking one of those guys to start
with is Tyreek because his speed is
going to force a lot of people to do
things that they don't want to do and
it's interesting when I watch the Chiefs
I know the ball is going to Kelce the
defense knows the ball is going to Kelce
he had 11 Targets in the first half I
mean it's not a surprise like hey who's
87 it's you got to stop momes and you
got to stop number 87 even when you know
that's when you know it's like
basketball when you got a guy who goes
I'm going to score on you and you can't
do anything about it can't do anything
about it and I'm going to tell you what
I'm going to do and you can't do
anything about it but DP this is what I
hear from like when we've been on the
road with uh some teams and defensive
guys what I hear from them is it's all
improv with them dudes like you could
study a thing on film right like I
played with Jason Whitten who I think is
one of the greatest tight ends to ever
play but Jason Whitten was gonna run an
option route and he was going to run a
scene and those were the two routes that
you had to try to stop now a lot of
people were very unsuccessful at it but
those were the thing man if you look at
some route combinations like we we have
this little thing that'll show you the
route combinations and what a guy did on
a particular route Travis Kelce look
like he's
zigzagging sometimes he just find an
open area him and Pat are so in sync
with with each other to your point like
basketball where it's like it's like
Malone and Stockton right it's like look
man we gonna run this pick and roll
there nothing you can do about it
because you don't know what you don't
know if I'm GNA pull up and shoot if you
try to double team call if you jump me
and jump the jump the screen I'mma drop
it off to him and oh by the way we got
these complimentary pieces out here that
I could kick out for a three-pointer
with with rice and with mikole I love
the fact that they got Meo back too um
his understanding it changes a lot but
Travis Kelce and and and Pat Mahomes
they impra Football week in and week out
and there's no defense for
that
are you a Laker
fan I'm a LeBron fan I'm a Pelicans fan
oh I'm a New Orleans Pelicans fan but
I'm a LeBron fan have you met LeBron
nope nope he shout me out on Twitter one
time it felt really good um he talked
about he uh he like when I'm on
TV um but I haven't met him in person he
actually his his youngest daughter Zuri
just started playing volleyball and you
know my daughter is number one playing
the country in volleyball and I
commented on his uh post when Zur is
playing I said welcome brother because
like if DP if you go to these volleyball
tournaments it's nothing but NBA and NFL
players watching their daughters it's
like a it's like the it's like a home
it's like a home a therapy home for
former pro athletes I used to see Tim
Duncan uh Tyson Chandler I used see
everybody um but uh I come in and he was
like yeah man congratulations to your
daughter she a beast and um my daughter
saw it and she was like that LeBron know
me I don't need I don't care about
nothing else so I can't tell her nothing
are basketball players
tough yeah I think they are because I
played compare compared to football
players
um I think it's a different kind of
tough right you got to think too though
a lot of these guys played
football like you you you know this
generation of like this generation of
NBA guys now are sports specific right
but if you go back to LeBron era and all
those guys before that we all were
multiple sport guys bro we all play what
do you think Michael Jordan would have
been like as a football player uh he
would have had the play wide receiver um
and I think he would have been really
good athletic long fast um strong would
he been Randy Moss
Noy no no nobody nobody's Randy
nobody could he have been the most
talented wat not the best but the most
talented receiver to ever play MJ no no
Randy Moss oh oh yeah yeah I think so
here's my thing DP
to Randy Jerry Rice and Calvin Johnson
to me and I put Jerry in there I don't
think Jared was like a a sick athlete no
I thought Jared was just a phenomenal
technician at what he did that
understood how to play the position
probably better than anybody ever but
those other three that I just named
those are the Elite athletes mix with
the ability to play receiver at a very
high level to me that's different than
anybody else I think Justin Jefferson is
trending in that direction it's going to
take a long time to get there I think
he's one of those guys that that could
potentially be in that conversation but
when it comes to Randy when it comes to
uh to and when it comes to Calvin
Johnson I think those are the guys
athletically and wide receiver rides
that are different than anybody else
yeah and fits in there too Larry Fitz
Juro is somewhere in there we don't
mention him I think because it wasn't
like super flashy like a lot of these
guys but if you go over fit's career big
physical hands were as sure as tax day
right like so it's uh it's a few guys
but them three for me with the
athleticism in the in the position are
different than everybody else good to
visit with you again thanks for joining
us we appreciate your time as always my
brother I still haven't got one of them
trinkets off your desk so can somebody
get on there please and you are welcome
to come down for a meet
Friday all right any Friday any Friday
you tell me when you're coming down you
tell me what you want to eat I'll fire
up the triggers and don't bring
orlovski I'm not going to bring orlovski
because we're going to have seasoning on
the food and the other thing is DP the
great thing about meat Friday on the
Trager is I can cook with you bro
because you know I know what I'm doing
on there you can do it all right fellas
how about we have a sleepover we'll have
a sleepover and then we do meet Friday
I'm with it let's record let's let's
let's film it let's film it okay all
right all right get a big ass sleeping
bag for me though DP I need a big
sleeping
bag Al also three uh sleeping bags
together to put you in there thank you
man all right my brother take Marcus
Spears he is the big swagu you can see
him with Laura rutage meet to Kim St
orlovski Ryan Clark NFL live every
weekday 4 in the afternoon